hey guys it's Thursday I'm Dan I'm just
and do remember if you want to count
just every single day of the week with
new musi bits and pieces you can hit
that subscribe button but for now here's
what happened today if you're still
plugging away at Pokemon go you're about
to be severely rewarded as legendary
Pokemon are finally making their way to
the app in order for the first one to
arrive though players around the world
will need to catch enough creatures
during the recently announced Pokemon go
fest challenge windows if that happens a
legendary will show up at Grant Park in
Chicago this Saturday if you don't
happen to live in Chicago not to worry
in future you'll come across legendary
eggs at gyms where you'll also have a
chance to fight and then catch these
creatures similarly to how you take on a
raid battle legendaries do differ from
other Pokemon though as you won't be
able to leave them behind in a gym to
defend it ahead of Pokemon go fest a new
update for the game has begun rolling
out which includes bug fixes refinements
and new features including the ability
to give berries to a Pokemon you've left
at a gym without having to visit it
remember those super cool outfits for
final fantasy 15 that made you look like
Power Rangers well they're coming out
soon also they make you dudes
Invincibles that's what that's right
following up on earlier DLC items like
the Nissen and cup noodle hat and the
Afrojack inspired sword
we've got these Power Rangers combat
soups that are actually called magitek
exosuits
the swanky outfits will arrive later
this month as a free update and once you
put them on your party will be
invincible for 30 minutes of course
swapping them on and off every half hour
wouldn't make for much of a game so you
can only use the suits once every 24
hours the suits were originally supposed
to arrive as part of the game's DLC
booster pack in February but were
delayed because well they look a lot
like the Power Rangers states in the
recent film they're also going to be
redesigned too so they look a bit less
trademark infringing in Call of Duty few
things are as sure as that packs mute
all and zombies and this year's Call of
Duty is getting zombies in the form of
nazi zombies Activision showed off a
trailer for Call of Duty World War two's
nazi zombies as part of their panel at
the San Diego Comic Con the trailer is
narrated by what appears to be a Nazi
scientist who Boise has not created a
new type of soldier but the devil
himself very creepy agreed the trailer
has a much darker horror vibe than
preemie
and trees which appears to be
intentional Glen Schofield co-founder of
developer sledgehammer games said this
is unlike anything before we're taking
players to some very dark grim places in
Nazi Zombies this is one hell of a
horror experience as with previous
entries you'll be playing as four zombie
hunters as they cooked peel back the
vile layers of a malevolent plot
masterminded by the Axis powers to
harness unimaginable occult forces and
create an invincible undead army
unfortunately the trailer doesn't show
off the diverse cast of David Tennant
Elodie yung Fruitopia Katheryn Winnick
and Bing Reims
but hopefully we'll see them in action
before the game's release on November 3
a beta will also be taking place before
launch that you can get into by
pre-ordering if you're so inclined that
is everything we've got for you today do
let us know your thoughts and feelings
on today's stories all whatever else
down in that comment section and be sure
to tune in tomorrow for our top five
stories of the entire week